la prestation canadienne d'urgence cette
fameuse aides financières disponibles
est facile à obtenir
c'est facile que vivian de ces rois l a
appris à ses dépens lorsqu'elle a reçu
une série de courriels de l' agence du
revenu du canada confirmant le dépôt de
trois demandes qu'elle n'avait pas fait
j'ai même pris quelques jours nous avons
décidé à appeler la jambe parce que sont
le coup je ne croyais pas et elle est
loin d'être la seule
les chiffres obtenus par le centre
antifraude du canada montrent que le
nombre de signalements de fraude a connu
une hausse importante en un mois en
juillet dernier on a compilé 1333
signalement pour des fraudes liées à la
pcu un mois plus tard le 31 ou 2565
signalement le double et ce ne serait
que la pointe de l'iceberg enchaînements
il faut de chalon nous études passées où
son anti fraude
les signalements qu'on recevait
représentait qu'une infime partie des
caisses qui existaient vraiment ça
pouvait être pas plus que 5% des photos
qui nous était signée ni de plus c'est
au québec que l'on compte le plus grand
nombre de signalements de là
l'importance de protéger ses données la
tête cet expert en expliquant jamais sur
un lieu inconnu dans un courriel et de
ne pas avoir qu'un seul mot de passe
unique pour tous ses comptes en ligne
une des façons qu'on a vu que les
délinquants sont capables de faire des
fausses de membres c'est en créant des
combes pour des personnes qui n'en
avaient pas jusqu'à maintenant pour sa
part viviane n'est pas au bout de ses
peines
son compte en ligne a été verrouillé par
l'agencé de revenu du canada
si j'ai besoin une pcu prochainement ça
pourrait être le corps je vais sur
commun la prestation canadienne
d'urgence prendra fin le 3 octobre
prochain pour être annexé à l'assurance
emploi
certains spécialistes croient maintenant
que les fraudeurs pourraient se tourner
vers les programmes date des provinces
pour continuer à détourner de l'argent
ici pascal robidas radio canada montréal